[Music]
okay and welcome to another live version
of worst fire team ever and we are the
worst because only three of us are here
we've Skyped in - you know the worst you
know the Midwest we Skype doing with
coke and he's got like you know as you
can see yeah he lives like a 12 year old
there's a Hulk in the background you
know your sponsorship on the left there
is that what you're doing the man cave
yeah yeah dude you know I got I got what
here's some deodorant you know I got to
stay fresh and then if he doesn't shower
hey yeah just to be on with these
[ __ ] I just got done training so I'm
I I need to take a shower but that's
very much this podcast means to me so
you have a fight coming up right you're
gonna be fighting right now you're gonna
be have a fight in Milwaukee right yeah
it's not announced but I think Anna now
- you have to hear it breaking news know
by the time this comes out we announced
then we made the official announcement
right here on fire but you have another
fight coming up to make another or one
of our rivals Grenadier Jake is a big
streamer plays a lot of destiny and when
the new dlc comes out what's the name of
it again
forsaken when the Forsaken DLC comes out
we're doing a one-on-one match we're
gonna have some undercard matches and
Coke is gonna go one-on-one with him in
the crucible for charity we haven't
picked the charities yet but it's going
to be for charity and we can't wait for
Grenadier Jake to beat his
[Laughter]
I'm putting my money on Grenadier jack
yeah I'll tell you this we should use an
online Betty wait people when when I win
oh we thought I was an [ __ ] to you
guys now no you can't gonna be it you're
Edgar [ __ ] just because I despise you
so much okay let's say the date so it's
gonna be September that's right
September 8th at 12:12 Pacific time so
we can get European people and everybody
to tune in we're gonna have some fun on
the under cards haven't been released
yet but it's probably gonna be Pikachu
and Craig are gonna be going at each
other cuz you know I'm gonna have a suit
on I'm gonna be the I want to be yeah
I'm gonna be me I'm gonna be the Joe
Rogan of gamer UFC yeah so we've been
playing this ridiculous grind on the
news events ourselves to get the 405
right is it's a lot what do you think
coke why you asking him you know because
I'm the only knowledgeable person piece
of [ __ ] have you have you finished there
we go no I love it and hate it at the
same time if that makes any sense it
gives us it gives us something to do
mm-hmm but at the same time you hate
doing it it's really [ __ ] weird man
hey you know Griffin can relate because
me and effing have talked about it I
don't know why we're still playing
destiny I just don't get to play like
every time I think I'm out it pulls me
back in you know yeah every day we just
play you know it's a game that like
because the game plays so fun we talked
about it before but the gameplay is fun
because and also to be honest there's a
drought of games right now there's just
not a lot out there right now no stuff
coming up
so I think we're gonna you're gonna see
us play some other game yeah because
like we saw the trailer today for Red
Dead
- and that looks sick and like that'll
be fun to like you know be playing and
streaming with that well yeah but some
of these games that you just like you
play them and then you finish it and
then there's nothing more nothing else
to do right so yeah that's I think
that's the thing about destiny is that
you you come back to it because you're
like well I
there's no end other stuff you can cry
and with the DLC there's always new
stuff like with the Forsaken coming out
there's like the hunt mode there's all
these different modes coming out gambit
we got gamble the random roles yeah
that's huge we watch the gameplay
yesterday yeah what random roles looks
amazing
shoulder charges for cranny mods have
they fixed a shoulder charge right
mouthing horribly one one hit one
shoulder charge back to that that's
gonna be great cokes gonna love it and I
know this nobody's like this is gonna
make this is gonna make Craig worse the
shoulder charge is gonna make Craig well
I and I'll tell you because now since
solders hearts doesn't work
now all Craig does is sit down like a
sniping lane with a vigilant swing and
spam and that Auto pulse rifle now
Craig's gonna go back the way he played
in destiny 1 and he's gonna run towards
people without even shooting his [ __ ]
gun so he's probably just gonna get and
I'm gonna tell you every time I as
what's gonna kill you could be so mad at
that well the last time we had you know
edit of matches coke went down let's put
that out there
Craig is now the gym
so it's like use a team captain Jam so
this will be a laugh I don't happen to
long enough or we off oh we can't hear
can't hear ourselves and uh in the
headphones anymore yeah when I talk yeah
when I talk I can hear you guys sorry
oh you just hit it Wow if you like
Fonzie alright so uh what I was gonna
say is this is really what we wanted to
say this is really an intervention for
Coco yeah
for anger management we wanted to work
out we want to work out yeah if you're
losing really kinda last week not oh
he's a sore loser
and even worse winner that's the problem
that is the problem so here's the other
thing too is that that you'll see it in
last week's episode because it'll be
it'll be last week's episode we
definitely we don't work even worse yeah
I'm slam right here's the thing let's
let's stop let's stop let's go back to
it okay Frank I'm gonna tell the whole
story just so people know are you gonna
see you'll see it but just know I did
not initiate it we didn't say anything
after the match was done I was gonna I
wasn't even gonna say anything
Craig had to open his his [ __ ] mouth
and that was it he knew wait wait wait
he can't have a little globe session for
beating you you can't when you have a
negative kd8 it's see here we go this is
name the last time we talked about this
yeah we were talking about how this is a
team sport when we do competitive right
so yet you know so when you're when you
have a LeBron James on your team you
don't have to score all the points
Craig was like Tristan Thompson
but I was started Craig I was Scottie
Pippin the regulatory whoa you weren't
scary right if we're gonna use
basketball is there any way in
basketball the team can deduct points
from your score because that's way hey
you can't get points for a hustle okay
so there so people can see that episode
because it'll be a success is a must
watch so much watch it's 2 V 2 to V 2 it
was definitely heated but it was fun to
do I mean so getting back to destiny as
a whole it's Forsaken so that's exciting
that they have the new dlc but like I
said I'm looking forward to some new
games we me and Pikachu watched Smash
Brothers and they announced like some
new characters yeah Castlevania and then
they also announced Dark Samus and then
cool was his name the crocodile guys
think King crop I think a rule yak a
roll so it's kind of cool it's like
there's finally some more games coming
out I'm excited for Soul Calibur 6 so
like hopefully you'll start to see more
games on our on our maybe yeah well I
mean one of the things is like okay so I
played three I play three games plus
sports games right yeah okay the three
games that I play are Battlefront
alright division yeah we should
definitely try division 2 and destiny oh
I'll say this I of all the games I still
always play come back to this yeah I'm
saying we will I'm saying out in front
like they they they change the scoring
and stuff so right it's fun but at the
same time it's the same their thing is
the same thing over and over again
without any and insensitive there's no
sense yeah right well I think I think
we're gonna like like I said we're not
leaving - destiny we're just gonna punch
out try other game we're just gonna have
other games cuz because we can also do
it at the same time like if me and peaks
want to play a fortnight and you guys
want to play destinies it you know what
we'll have ways to do both but but I do
think that it's it's just it is hard to
get away from destiny it is like
Godfather 3 it's just like it is you
know I think it's I think it's the
smooth gameplay you
Bunji they may [ __ ] up and a lot of
things but they one thing that they know
ever since they started halo is how to
make smooth first-person shooters
yeah true so I mean that does bring you
back it and also with the with the rolls
now it'll be interesting to see because
I remember when Frank was doing destiny
one he had the grass with Malik with
like his guttural yeah and like he was
kind of unstoppable when we were first
playing cuz of the gun and now it's like
I hope they find a way to balance that
though so you don't feel super under
power to somebody as a gobbler well this
is the thing every time they try to do
that they ruin it you should just leave
it yeah so what you have somebody let it
be chaotic yeah because then what
happens is only people with like you
know you know super hero [ __ ] hand-eye
coordination like this the purpose of
the sense of the grind
I want to because everybody's armors to
saying I think they need to bring back
to tree to tree but yeah there's gonna
have an additional trees for the new
supers and then there have random roles
where you can customize them I said oh
right yeah I mean well it'll be
interesting to see I mean it's
definitely a big update and it's it's
needed cuz Destiny's definitely been
starved for good content for a while I
was thinking who-who should we get to be
in the under cards for our September 8th
main event
yeah hater Jake and you probably have
some other friends that play just me as
well we should get the guys who we play
with a lot yeah arrow and grant we can
like arrowverse CAV I think that would
be a good match we should reach and
we're gonna reach out to you to people
out there that are got some fibers on
her Twitter all 17 of you guys that
watch it yeah guys want to play with us
if you want to be in the undercard we're
gonna we're gonna have like a play in
tournaments what we should do right
we'll figure it out you'll see us on our
on our Twitter and our Instagram and
we'll get some people to play with us
but we got to get some good undercard
yeah I did see that that that we got
that fan art that did that picture me
yeah they got the hair drawn from the
mine shoutout to John from the mine yeah
drawn the other
from the minding yeah it was good you
should have been a hand cannon though
you would and it should have been a
hunter okay okay yeah that'd be too big
he didn't get the anger right either it
should have been yeah my face was too
calm in that picture your face is never
that happy now I'm happy I'm happy I'm
happy whenever I get to roast Craig I'm
actually happy on another side note I
want to get your guy's opinion because
they're talking about now 2019 which is
around the corner being ps5 which means
if it's ps5 means new xbox
I'm tired of buying new Xbox so that's
the question right like I have Xbox s
and I have Xbox X it's like right unless
it's so much better than ur or different
but you know that's the thing like
they'll be back I know they'll do
backward compatibility but they'll start
cutting that off after a year or two
easily yeah yeah so it's like it's kind
of trippy because we're at a point now
we're like the the increase right
because like Xbox one X if you have a 4k
it's nice but it's not like life change
yeah that's what you need though right
they should be coming out with is like
monitors as opposed to just the unit but
yeah if you have a 4k it does change the
game
right for recipe you'd like to suggest
these a beautiful game right what is it
that much of a leap that you were like
oh god I gotta have it
I gotta have a you know PS 5 for 4k you
know I mean like it's I wanted to X but
F when I look back on it I didn't need
it right that's the thing having that
was good enough yeah well he was I
wanted to just to have one that I could
travel with and one you know and that's
just a second here yeah stay at home you
know right but now if I have to get
another one I don't know yeah that's the
question like it's a weird time because
I feel like so many people feel so
invest in the console they have already
and it's it's not that big of a
graphical leap so it's like yeah it
would have to be something can I really
spend $500 yeah like is it even that
like unless they come out and say like
like the gameplay is so much better like
yeah like you just had the reaction time
is instantaneous if it's something like
that then maybe but if it's not like why
I what's then cyclist dance
I mean I think what they're gonna do is
what they always do which is try to
pitch you on new games just for that
system and then that and that man yeah
but not hook what can they even do
though it's it's at a speed right now
that what probably it'll do the new halo
for the new cut Xbox yeah but what
what's it gonna be what how much faster
can it be like what are they gonna it's
not about faster so what is it because
it's already 4k we already got 4k Cabaye
night lady I don't know that's the thing
it's just more textures more you know
it's it's but the problem is it's not
like the leap from like sd to HD you
know what I mean that's right that's the
big problem we have is like is like
we're kind of it's diminishing returns
you know like the law of diminishing
returns it's like so it's like it's
weird that they're talking about it
already because it's like it feels still
kind of premature and I just don't know
what it's in you know what they're gonna
sell you on is what they try to do with
these last ones I connect or maybe VR
well first of all they what they need to
do is get rid of that [ __ ] Kinect
gear is trash they so stupid but they
need to just make it worse what it
should be automatically integrated into
the Xbox what are the boss you know I
wouldn't want that because unless they
had like a turning on top like a turn
but what they need to do is you should
be able to hook up any [ __ ] webcam
you want to that's to your xbox and they
should have audio and video cuz right
now you can hook up just video you can
hook up any mmm-hmm but that should just
be something this integrated it's just
so stupid this dumb Kinect and then they
don't even sell a connector they don't
even sell the poor you have to get this
separate adapter thing it's so stupid
trash you ever connect oh that's what
he's using yeah that's what I'm using
right now oh it's the worst yeah I mean
I definitely think they screwed up when
they launched the system and force you
to like get it and use it like well they
thought that those like live action
games like that like jumping around
games like hitting things for the ninja
yeah not worried it did not look at like
what you're playing right there you're
playing in like a little game closet
that you have in your place
he'd like move over is like roid-rage
stuff there's not enough space most
people don't have enough space to just
let me move my coffee table and we move
my couch to do this yo game if if you
saw to start showing up at my door
testing me more often I'm blaming you
guys no yeah he should be tested does it
even matter though they should just let
I mean well telling these people go beat
yourselves up get to a pulp but like
don't do a thing that will like help you
take the damage better or I don't know I
don't know Roy yeah well steroids are
just bad for you in general so I mean
it's it may give you an energy drink to
- you're right they're caffeine caffeine
is okay their constant bangs let me tell
you something cocaine is a crack in a
can Oh gave me this stuff it looks like
cocaine powder you know a little like
drug bag and and it's called I am God
and it's like one night I'm tired and
I'm like I really want to go to bed no
no just take some of that we'll play so
I take some dude and I start getting a
bender dude I was up till 7 a.m. and I
was like sweating and I was like why
would you do that like it's not it
doesn't even make sense and then you're
doing that before a workout you're just
you love's like you know oh that's why
Oh Mike but this is the kind of guy
that's working out like you get you're
just like
yeah cuz you can't do the roids he's got
to do this I bet your work out is never
simple your work I've been working out
yeah so Griffiths start boxing so four
more weeks you and coke can start going
against each other under cards gonna be
me beating you up yeah I'll do it I'll
do oh speaking of boot camp
oh there could you go to boot care well
I did so Pikachu our baby like a little
baby
yeah I went to boot camp yesterday with
Craig and beforehand we ate tacos and I
ate too many top you gotta hold the [ __ ]
on you're on your way to go workout and
you stopped at a taco place no no we
went beforehand like a couple hours
before I was hungry okay
it was it was lunchtime but so we get to
we get to boot camp mm-hmm and we're
doing the stuff
Pete's doing good he's running he's
doing some weights and and then all of a
sudden like I could slowly see his face
start to change yeah I'm like it went
from like enjoying the work out to like
breathing heavy and looking like you
know it's do you smoke no anyway at
least you wouldn't have that annoying
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] nasally voice huh no
he's still in slow roll of a joke there
was police - would it have I can't hear
you guys when I talk into my mic so like
if you're talking right now I can't hear
you
it's also cuz you just don't listen well
well I'm you can see the rain well
listen well I I try to [ __ ] make
these guys better players and nobody
knows
he thinks he's Pat Riley you're not
destiny you're like what was that
that Coach did the Cleveland fired you
veteran Lou no no one before
would you like your black the guy from
the overseas that's you man
so but going back to our workouts what
happened yeah so what happened well I
was doing good you know talking to them
ladies and then at the very end we're
stretching talking to one girl that was
really into pique she was like how who's
your little friend no who's the 12 year
old you brought did she want to adopt
him she might have actually so I'm
stretching than an out of norm link well
I don't feel great and then I threw up
all the talk I threw up yeah I know that
it was so sad I had to take him to this
located off area because there's no
restrooms and put him in the back by a
chicken coop and he was like green in
the face and he sat there pretty much
better afterwards
that's all gray afterwards what did you
take him for to get tacos that's a good
plot that's a good spot where the
plancha I love plancha on Thun third you
never been there
oh that's okay it's healthy it was just
all right he was just you know he had he
overate lay over a I don't normally work
out sometimes when I like not like that
he doesn't work out works out on like he
just puts his fanny pack on in his
shorts and Hank I know there we go
the Pikachu's trying to be like God
that's right he told me he's wearing the
fan whatever anyway he was a Walmart I
got a bunch of sweat suits how Lindsay
puts up with that but no but we had a
good time otherwise and then I got to
meet Pikachu's family that was yeah tell
us about Pikachu's oh oh yeah
we hit it off she's very nice lady is
this a good time yeah my mom is single
now Oh ready to mingle
yeah maybe I don't know she was kind of
inviting me to a Big Bear trip you know
I have to think about it oh Jesus
because you look sad he needs a dad
though right am i right guys he needs a
dad not you I like that cokes like vying
for the position you don't want to be a
dad you know I don't want gonna be his
dad but if Craig was my dad I'm telling
you you couldn't make me do a [ __ ]
thing I would literally do everything
opposite he told me to do yeah when my
kids on roids and just pounding like
kick him out the house I don't want to
deal with that go live in your game
closet yeah
but no you got a nice family's got a
little brother who plays games what wait
wait hold on a little brother well
here's the funniest taller than me the
family is taller his mom's taller than
me how's your sister hold your sister I
don't know like hey she's taller than
Pikachu so she's like 135 Pikachu
isn't it aren't you like one inch off
from legally being a [ __ ] yeah that
sucks you can't get all the benefit a
little on the benefits we get for you're
arguing one inch away from that from
like having an easier parking situation
and all that yeah I know it's a bummer
I'm gonna help me out driver no we could
have got some government funding for our
podcast nobody has a nice family we had
a good time Craig was trying a lot
really hard last night I was bought my
family to do the thing is like he's like
trying to hook us up his time hey talk
to my mom Oh what are we doing mom and
then like and then later he's like stop
hitting on my mom so it's like quicken
your price yeah I was trying to slide in
with the newly single mom I just I don't
know what this cracked egg for oh you're
getting mention I'll get Manship - no no
my flirting zone
like you like that you like that Korean
barbecue Oh
[Music]
now but we we had a good time we did go
to Korean barbecue and it was guess all
that's the best base of the our thing
yeah there's two things we like to do
destiny and Korean bar it's too
addictive yeah I rode the soul to man
rode the souls my favorite out out -
Road - so let's get some sponsorship
from right now it was brought to you by
wrote as old but but if we have a good
time we hung out and we've got to meet
the family and they're a nice family
Pikachu is weird about everything don't
Pikachu has this weird thing that I
noticed that I got to bring up oh hey
this is what he does he says don't don't
tell them about this don't tell them
about that don't worry about this
anybody cares like don't tell don't tell
anybody about my podcast don't tell them
what we're doing with that gaming it's
like what do they care it's like a point
yeah this finally takes off then you
know you'll be like and it'll be taking
him to Korean barbecue yeah
that is so funny dude yeah he gets weird
about it he was grilling me all day
don't tell them but this don't tell them
but actually his family's really nice
his brother has a deeper voice than him
which I expected Oh sounds like his
brother looks like he's like you know a
teen peaks looks like he's 12 it's weird
I know there's a deep voice yeah death
Wow it's kind of like Mork and Mindy you
know or it's like Pikachu's like
Jonathan winters buddies he's actually
the older one yeah but don't know this
Pikachu is actually 38 it's like but
nobody you know nice family your sister
was quiet yeah she's like a lot we have
I was gonna meet your sister one day
that's true mm-hmm you know and then I
showed up late for the movie no it was
her it was her she's just an angry
person and she was just like I'm not I'm
not coming now cuz I think we had got a
laters yeah yeah but that man I've met
Lindsay Lindsay's a coax girlfriend is
very very nice lady very nice she's nice
I don't know why it's not but
Jim - though oh yeah she was lifted she
was deadlift high now
I like alright like a Volkswagen when
she's wait she wants to keep up with the
you know cracking of like when you have
to work out the [ __ ] code I will say I
got her doing it I got her into it so I
mean she goes she goes to my same
strength & Conditioning guy so we do it
together it's kind of like a couple
thing we do if yeah yeah but they're
young enough I mean at least she's young
enough I don't know about coke she's
really young I said I should be I should
be I should be someone you look up to
then Craig it's never too late I don't
want to do all that crack I'm talking
about losing the guts so something else
we need to come up we have to change
some some usernames we need to
officially change Craig's name to TDF
bro I think you got a I want to hit up
cuz everybody keeps asking about where
Steve and again Steve's taking a break
he's working on those other music we
talked to him he might be back at some
point we don't know when so just you
know quit asking quit asking yeah
driving in our me crazy and Frank
couldn't be here today because he's
working but normally he he wanted to be
here today
yeah we got some big stuff coming up
we're also gonna have a big event in the
next few months
mm-hmm along with the the one-on-one
match the big main event for that we're
also gonna have another big podcasting
type event we're gonna at this place out
and where's it at Huntington Beach
Huntington meets honey the beach cuz
they got these big mega screen right
yeah and we're gonna just play we're
gonna invite
bunch of people to come watch yeah and
we do some one-on-one I have a lot of
music and other weird stuff maybe some
foods we're gonna figure it out yeah so
look out keep watching and look out for
that if you're in the California area
and you're interested in that kind of
thing stay in touch with us and we'll
write you know about that and then also
working on some other stuff or work on
decals me yeah we might have some decals
very very soon controllers and if and if
you want to get a vanguard game unit you
can get a discount we'll have a discount
code for that that thing is I did you
get one yet go I know know how he's
going to order one but I still haven't
got it yet I think we might be able to
get you one yeah we might also have like
a giveaway contest with one so we'll see
what's going on there what they allow
yeah so so yeah we got some cool things
coming up we're gonna keep doing or
gonna keep playing destiny hopefully
some other games I'm Koka me have a
match coming up for Soul Calibur 6 when
that comes out so yeah we got our we got
our tournament going there let's just
say let's just say I haven't picked up
what what what game is that is that an
xbox it's not even Xbox is it yeah it's
Dreamcast no its Xbox you know like what
Xbox it's so old I can't even [ __ ]
room is the new one so caliber 6 is not
out yet
we talked no the one we played the one
we played already uh-huh that was so
caliber two we played in my house on
Soul Calibur 2 and now my were they the
terms were best two out of three I won I
won at two out of three he somehow made
up there's two out of three thing one
the first match I I think I won the
first but he won like the second two
yeah and and and but the thing was that
I had never said two out of three
winners win I never even said it he
literally was like okay that's two or
three at one and I was like wait a min
ever agreed it to another three I just
agreed to play we lost him where we lost
you for a second I'll just do his voice
Greg
that's pretty much it you know we lost
you it we lost you coach yeah we're here
can you hear us his controller it was a
thumb thumbs up if you could hear thank
God I wish that happened more often I
wish I had been more off of where his
controller just wit out there you are
but no Craig ended up winning later on
cuz he just wanted to keep playing but I
won the two out of three and that's what
I tell maybe the two or three even
though you made it up on the spot like
literally he was like I said after the
second match I said okay winner the next
one wins and then I did it and then I
made it up as we were going along it
didn't matter
I mean the end point is we'll have a
rematch with Soulcalibur six will do
that when that game comes out and we'll
have some fun what's this I was more way
more competitive way more competitive Oh
Craig stupid old ass stupid [ __ ] game
than he is with me and destiny so ain't
this anger management we got to get the
number yeah we got to get the number for
anger management you know we gotta get
some FIFA FIFA 2018 we should do and you
know how to play we should set up a day
match with you and one or both the
brothers yeah the to get about the Lee
brothers yeah cuz you know they'll do a
game of that and that'll be fun to just
get a recording of that one night so
what about the ones that come out oh
fallout fallout comes out in November
yes we're gonna play that we'll try it
out yeah follow yeah mostly play it out
we can't try it out we have to buy it
yeah yeah but we'll do that I mean
follow it looks great because it's
finally multiplayer the only thing I
don't like about downloading games is
the fact that you can't return them yeah
that's true you should be able to return
them that you should just just erase it
from my system oh yeah maybe like a
discount but I will tell you this like
cuz I was I always bought game discs and
my buddy with our uni is like why don't
you just get you know digital downloads
and I'm like because you know what I
could still sell this now of course you
go to Game Stop and they're like here's
25 cents but if you go on to like eBay
or like if you hold on to the game for a
long time like sometimes
like go up in value and so it's not
gonna be for games like you know black
ops 2 or whatever that's like Craig's a
hoarder
that's Jeff that's why I collect so much
because I sell them all they make money
the hoarder denial languages collector
but that being said it says so I like
buying the game discs because at least
you have something to return and get
back yes i IE man i have some games
what's that stupid DC game injustice
justice a hundred dollars i spent on
that game I want my money oh my god I
played it it was like $99 for like this
ultimate edition yeah yeah you know but
I went to that guy turned that game on
the other day and they did keep adding
so they keep adding and I'm trying to
make people come back to it and play for
that game but you know what door here's
something that was weird with that with
you is that you would put it on hard oh
I like playing things on the hard mode
yeah like that what I completed the game
on easy oh yeah I wanna I like like I do
the challenge like I never completed
Goldeneye on Dreamcast because I only
wanted to play it on the hardest loan
engine and I stopped playing at halo
because that legendary level on Halo was
just insane well that's the thing like I
I like I like to play through games and
I like I just like regular like I don't
I want to do normal I don't want to go
super hard I'm not one of those guys
there's people have challenge
yeah but then there's games like Dark
Souls or they do like us and those games
are hard enough to start with it's
alright and then I don't want to get
sucked into one game for 40 hours just
to prove I could do it on hard like I'm
but I just want to get through it and I
go back that's and but injustice is so
hard yeah on the hardest level you can't
even get past you can't even get a hit
in you're forgetting juggled in there
yeah yeah the first the first fight you
can't get past it
I was playing for an hour just to see I
was like can you get better and it's one
of those things where you just if you
don't have twelve-year-old fingers yeah
if you don't have like yeah you cuz I
don't know because then you play on I
playing online for get it right you
playing online these people are just
like
yeah this is not fun I'm not having fun
no you know so that being said though
there's a lot of games fighting games
coming out I'm still looking forward to
someone oh I don't know why we never
play the UFC game they were giving that
for free that's why because it was free
you don't like you don't like a coke I I
feel like with those games it's so hard
to figure out every single system you
know I'll tell you my biggest problem do
you mean you're talking about like the
fight mechanic like the grappling and
yeah like like like it's I just feel
like they haven't found the best way to
like implement it using a controller so
it's too hard well my problem was like
when they first did it I really liked it
because it was mostly buttons you just
use buttons or RB and things to
transition and and now if you gotta use
the stick oh yeah once you start having
to like turn it's like semicircle and
I'm like dude I don't that's like it's
too calm I don't like you want to right
right four five six seven eight
yeah it's actually ten different
controls on the on the game right right
right but also like when you're using
the stick to control like transitions
and movements and grapple it's it's so
like it's not precise you know what I
mean like that's what's great with like
a game like destiny you press the
trigger it shoots if I gotta use a stick
to figure out how to do semicircle it
was more like Batman because Batman that
fight confirm yeah it was like smooth
yeah well that's the thing is like
that's how the original USC game was it
was mostly button button and and and for
what you know they want to change it up
and when once they started going to like
using sticks as opposed to buttons I
tuned out I just don't like using sticks
for the game those are not too big games
anymore I remember when like Tekken
Tekken still really big is it they just
announced a new Tekken right they just
announced that evil after the
championships that they're gonna have
negan in the game from walking Darius
yeah Tekken's big initely Tekken it
there's a new debtor alive new tech ins
out I play Tekken I mean I have it I
played it it's fun it's an Xbox oh yeah
yeah and they have a street fighter
Street Fighter and that also wasn't it
it wasn't injustice which was the one
like mortal combat with teens we ninja
turtles and everything they have like a
lot of stuff Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles they added to that too was
immortal or I wouldn't mind finding a
good fight game for us to play I'm down
any time I love fight game I loved
Mortal Kombat yeah we could do some
Mortal Kombat bigger sure yeah that is
great stuff when they have a lot of good
DLC for the games - they have like Mike
do leather face and yeah wow yeah they
have like fun characters so I'm
surprised that that who makes Batman
it's Rocksteady which was now owned by
Warner Brothers I'm surprised they
haven't their work what a new they've
not even a DLC well they're working on
new games so they got some like they're
working on something especially with the
new injustice movies yeah they're
working on something Rocksteady but they
kind of finished with that last Batman
game like they were kind of like rocks
and he's like this is the last one I
think we're doing that's too bad yeah
last Batman games are great but they're
working on something new but you know
there's still a lot games coming now I
mean like Spider Man looks dope but I
know most of you guys don't like more
but spider-man looks really good the
only game I loved on the was that one
infamous informations great great Peter
that's the same companies making
spider-man yeah well that's all that's
great but I gave my ps4 away yeah what I
got 2x boxes of that come on yeah just
gonna my xbox house yeah we decided but
you're gonna have to get that PS 5 now
so no Coco's talking about this to that
yes controller II suck it's too small
well so they have a new controller
that's awesome for PlayStation made by
stuff but it's $200 yeah it's like the
pro can see it's like the pro controller
like I really want once I agree the
PlayStation controllers are the worst
that the the cramping and also the nubs
rub off like yeah they'll break yeah
that should happen so often that people
don't know this but you could just you
could there's a thing you could contact
and they'll just send you a new one yeah
like it's not even like they know they
made a mistake it's oh it's a design
flaw yeah like I never have you'll get
that with the Xbox after like a thousand
years of playing but ya know there's one
game I was playing with because some of
the games where you have to lie
use that control stick or whatever it is
and this [ __ ] just kept rubbing off from
yeah not like this
yeah well that's why I like I really
want the scuf controller but it's so
late in the game for a ps4 and $200 that
I'm like $200 is half the cost of the
house and I don't know why it's not like
the elite cuz the elites like one 151
150 and some of they go on sale and we
need to convince some of these people to
just send us some control yes well I
mean media manager yeah nobody but yeah
there's some good games coming out
though like that like I mean like
spider-man will be awesome because it's
like infamous but same company I mean I
just love open-world games yeah go back
to Batman again but one of the things I
loved about that game was like you could
be working on ten missions at the same
time yeah yeah just depending on where
you were in the game I just loved well
read dead like we saw Red Dead the
trailer came out today looks very very
immersive really like awesome gameplay
look somebody's what is that one so Red
Dead Redemption if you never played the
first ones rock started as GTA and it's
their Western yeah Cowboys and the first
one was amazing like it was out on 360
and it was like it was like blue you
know it's just they also make that one
where you had that it was just like GTA
be get that you're hacking in what was
that you're thinking of I know what
you're thinking of uh god they made this
watchdogs yeah yeah I loved watchdogs
but it well it was open world but yeah
why no that's that was Ubisoft this is
um this is this is GTA this is a
rockstar they've been working on this
game I think for like eight years or
like well like it's it's been that
Western game well that's really really
and it's it's just like you know they're
so good at world building I mean they're
the king of open-world games with GTA
you know what I mean and and it's weird
that they're still releasing content for
GTA 5 I mean that's crazy I know that
they're still releasing content coke no
I think I I got it and then I got it the
first day and the servers they had so
many people on it that the servers
crashed and I got so [ __ ] mad that I
just took the baggins oh yeah take this
back to your your rage problem yeah
so you missed out on my combine I was
really pumped for it and like I tried I
tried for probably six hours to load in
and login and I'm like [ __ ] this they
don't know you know I know I just played
this like about couple months ago I
started GTA again because I wanted to do
this thing where you can you know how
you can invest the money so you could
end up with a billion dollars yeah
there's a certain way you have to do it
and I wanted to do that right and it was
just like but that game was like I'm
consuming yes it's time-consuming but
you know what happened that live thing
cope was screwed up for six months like
it when they that's crazy yeah when they
finally went live it was there were so
many people trying to get on and so much
stuff that like they it took them six
months it was really they like that's
why they gave people like Inc they game
like in currency like two million
dollars or something just to make up for
the fact that they were screwed up for
so long but that being said they really
are the king of open-world games and
like so Red Dead Redemption 2 is gonna
be pretty massive and the stories
they're great at telling stories I mean
that's one thing but that's just a
Western yeah it's a Western but like
you're with the game gang you're fleeing
but times are changing everything's
becoming modernized right and like and
like you I guess you're building
relationships with your game yeah and
then the other open-world game I brought
last time too but I'm kind of sad now as
cyberpunk 2077 I think and the reason
I'm upset about it is cuz it sounds like
it's still like years away even though
they showed an amazing trailer for e3
yeah they showed an amazing trailer but
we have to put something out I know I
know but they were working on for 5
years before they show the trailer so
it's like so like it might be if they're
gonna wait like even another year it
might like in the next call that's what
I'm saying it's gonna be next gen so
it's like that's what's killing me now
is like you see a lot of games that's
why I think Sony's conferences here at
e3 was so slim like they showed like
three or four big games that were all
gameplay metaphor is that's trending
yeah but the thing was is that they I
think they're not showing new new stuff
because they're planning now on like
getting it for the next system but they
don't the from what I understand is they
don't even make profit off their game
consoles
most of the profit today is being off
the games and like in over their life
and then they're like they're live like
Xbox Live Marketplace kind of purchases
yeah in game purchases yeah I mean when
the first Xbox came out like I think it
was like they were losing like three
four hundred dollars a box yeah and you
know but and that was ten all right but
at that time that was to that was to get
a market share that for that especially
for the first Xbox they just wanted to
carve a niche because they're competing
with you know Nintendo Sony I think even
know they still they've been put out of
business it feels like switch is doing
great it's done way better than Wii U
the big problem for switch right now is
like III was just super disappointing
because all they showed was Smash
Brothers and yeah looks great but they
didn't show anything else so what's
coming out this neck like there's no
like a Nintendo exclusives no there's no
there's like they obviously have games
in the pipeline but I'm getting nervous
that they might try to do like an like
what PlayStation Xbox I'm doing like a
step up like a switch act now is the the
switch is that same kind of thing like
the Wii where you have like - well the
switch you know it's a portable all the
ports you can press it down you have
like two controllers like that we use
yeah and you could I wish there wouldn't
be great if Xbox made that way like you
could well destiny onna the rumor is
Sony might be working on like a PS 5
life they already had something like
that well they have the Vita that
there's a Vita version but like like the
idea of the switch which makes it great
is it's a home console or it's a to go
console so like like you plug it in and
you do it on your TV or you take it out
and you go to go but the problem is is
like they have a drought of games right
now it's kind of frustrating because
like they had all this momentum and it's
like oh there's nothing smash brothers
that's it for kriby
no on and while we're yeah what's up try
stalking I mean Kyle
dates
go ahead was there any new updates on
autumn anthem is interesting because
I've been reading articles on it and the
main thing is like people are nervous
about it because they feel like the the
world-building is might not be as good
as we hope and there and if they make a
good point like when you look at
Destiny's game plays great but you know
sometimes the story lags you know like I
mean yeah the stories is yeah Chris
Jesus I don't even know what this I
don't know what this story for this one
is theirs right literally no store right
yeah and so that's kind of the the same
worry they have for anthem is that
you're gonna get this game that's fun to
play with people and jump in and out of
but what's the third use story if it's
like you need a great story if at the
end of the story the game's over right
well right but I'm in love with it you
know but that's the thing anthem is like
destiny in third person so it's like
they're trying to build the EA version
of destiny and I'm more open world yeah
and more of the world but I mean we'll
just have to see I mean you know I'm not
gonna I'm gonna wait and see you know
it's just like what's interesting now is
because you can fix games too and in
like Destiny's doing that all the time
and no man sky just did a big update
where they're trying to like come back
to like making it something and that's
something you couldn't do in past
consoles is like you make big downloads
in like fixed games you know what I mean
and so so with the anthem even if it
comes out and it's not great at first
like like kind of like division right
like it started out in your Leia and
then like it started to keep making more
and more I think like of those type of
games like Battlefront division in and
destiny mmm-hmm I think like Destiny's
in the middle of both of them
yeah it's like battlefront looks
beautiful yeah right graphics are
amazing the crevices so the world's
billet the gameplay isn't quite as
smooth right that division is so
complicated right like the armor too
much things going on oh man it should be
fluid but but it's fun to fix your armor
and and have to get all the things for
it but yeah that's these just the one
you go okay this is the middle grand
Here I am again
playing the media heroic strike you know
quit play but the great thing those
[ __ ] those [ __ ] strike catalyst
man I've been grind in trying to get the
merciless 1s where they don't drop that
I'm doing I'm working on that Sturm one
right now but actually the Sturm and
Drang
combination because they reload each
other's ammo really yeah so letting you
you don't even have to reload like you
could like shoot shoot shoot switch and
then if you if you use one of those if
you use a piece of SATA Carmer that
gives you like fast reload that's gun
what would you know gun switch and yeah
there's one for the warlock you know if
you use one of those with the drag and
Ophidian aspects yeah if you use that
with this term and I think it's pretty
dangerous thing yeah
well be it's all gonna change come when
forsaken comes out I mean that's the
other don't bring back all the old guns
you know are you are you worried for
when you fight Jake we be like
accustomed to like the change of the
load outs and everything or you think
you'll be fine regardless of what the
load up change might be well what I
think is cool about it and this is why
it was my idea to do it is it's before
the meta actually comes out so no one
will really know whether your idea under
no well know what like the most powerful
weapon is so it's I think it's just
gonna be more what we're comfortable
with and we won't have enough time to
take a like a gun rule to have like the
best loadouts coke will still be
grinding together the night before like
I need that I need that God role hand
cannon oh dude I'll be [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
I'll be doing it the whole goddamn week
yeah he's gonna be on that crash I'm
ready I'm gonna be I'm gonna be three
bangs deep man I'm gonna be [ __ ]
losing it yeah is that a bun you have
one long beautiful hair like this
all right I'm done with the Adonis all
right I think that's a pretty much our
our so I guess guys check in September
8th mm-hmm at check-in before that check
in before that but tune in for sure
September 8th 12 p.m. pursue and we're
gonna like I said we're gonna be doing
it for charity we're gonna be donating
and all that I'll be coke versus
Grenadier Jake and we'll have some on
their cards if anybody wants to reach
out and be a part of stuff just hit me
up on Instagram my worst fire team ever
hit us up on Instagram worst fire team
ever we're gonna have some other big
things coming up and we have some decals
and stuff and some merch we're working
on so yeah a lot of cool stuff and yeah
just keep tuning in and thanks for you
know second by sticking with us plug um
what am i plug in nothing playing at the
Toronto comedy fest now okay Craig will
be at boot camp not be tacos boot camp
with Peaks alright are you guys
[Music]